now let's get some more reaction to last
night's special sky news leadership
program rishi sunak and liz trust
clashed over the economy after that
stark warning of spiraling inflation
from the bank of england so let's get
the reaction then of the business and
energy secretary and list trust
supporter quasi-quatting a very good
result
good to see you so let's start with that
bank of england prediction that we heard
yesterday
they said that households are going to
suffer their biggest squeeze on income
on record the economy is going to suffer
a year-long recession and some and
inflation is going to hit 13.3
this year
could this have been managed differently
i think the problem we have is very
simple i think we've got uh inflation
which is as you say squeezing people's
incomes but we also got a rising tax
burden
and that's why i'm supporting liz trust
i've never understood why
if we're going to
help people how we're going to help
people by putting up their taxes
especially when their daily shop their
costs
are going up and what's very clear to me
from what the bank of england said
yesterday is that more of the same just
simply carrying on with our economic
policy at the moment
is not going to cut it it's not going to
help us get out of this difficulty and
actually the imf only 10 days ago
predicted that we would be the lowest
growth g7 economy
we can't tax ourselves
to growth and that's everyone
understands that everyone around the
world nobody's saying we're going to
help our people by putting up taxes and
that's what we're doing in this country
so it's interesting that you're putting
the blame on rishi sunax and what tax
rises yeah and yet the bank of england
were explicit about where the rise in
inflation came from they say it's rising
energy prices they largely blame the
actions of russia for our economic
problems so is it fair to blame rashidi
i'm not blaming the tax rises but
put very simply
you've got a world where prices are
going up so people's shop people's
energy bills are all going up so that
means their real incomes are being
squeezed
now to say to people your real incomes
are being squeezed and i'm going to put
your taxes up i think it's just adding
insult to injury you're not actually
dealing with the problem and the way to
deal with the problem is to have a
slightly looser fiscal approach and
that's what rishi himself implied
yesterday he said he would help people
now if you're going to help people and
have an intervention that is a looser
approach than simply hiking up taxes to
a 70-year high which is where we are
today okay and i want to come on to
what we do about it in the future and
what could be done for the for the
poorer people but i do want to get to
the bottom of
why we've got to where we are now i mean
what do you think of how the bank of
england has handled this do you feel
that they should have raised interest
rates earlier so there is an argument
and i think it's a strong one to say
that inflation was an issue that was
identified
at the beginning of uh last year
and in fact i think um people bank of
england commentators uh even people in
the treasury were saying that this was
an issue and the job of the bank was to
deal with the inflation they've got a
two percent inflation target that's
actually their mandate um and now
inflation is hitting double digits so
clearly something's gone wrong and i
think there is an argument to suggest
that rates should have probably gone up
uh slightly sooner so is the bank of
england fit for purpose i think look to
say that it's not fit for purpose i
think is is wrong i think it's a a good
institution i think it's worked well uh
but we need to look again
at what the mandate is and how best they
can actually fulfill that mandate what
does that mean well that means that if
your target is two percent and you're
predicting 13
uh something's gone wrong and you've got
to look at how uh the bank is is is
organized and what the what the targets
are
will it keep its independence under a
liz trust i think it's absolutely gonna
keep its independence but so how would
it change if you have a target anna if
you have a target that's two percent and
you're predicting 13
something's gone wrong something's gone
wrong it's a hugely missed target you've
missed your two percent and that's not
because of global factors like there
were lots of global factors but people
have been talking about inflation for
the last two years and i think there is
an issue about how uh the bank is
operating because clearly if you've got
a if i say to you two percent is your
target and you say to me well actually
the time the uh it's gonna hit 13 i
would quite rightly say something's gone
wrong we've got to look at how uh you're
performing so something has gone wrong i
mean this is a an economic crisis isn't
it so i think it's a global crisis uh
compounded of two things
firstly of course we have the covid
pandemic large parts of the world the
advanced economies were shut down and
then all of a sudden they opened and
there was huge amounts of demand and the
supply couldn't keep up with it so that
forced prices up and then on top of that
you've got the russia
ukraine crisis which actually had a
knock-on effect on energy prices because
russia essentially is turning off its
gas supply to uh western europe so those
two factors have give put a lot of uh
pressure in the system and rishi was
right it's not it's the tax rises
themselves yeah didn't cause this but to
have tax rises in this context i think
is is is is very odd okay so an economic
crisis then so where's the chancellor uh
the chancellor
is always uh available uh and he's
someone who didn't hear from him
yesterday this grim warning from the
bank of england i mean is he on holiday
um i'm in contact with him i've just uh
spoken to him well what's up this
morning he's completely abreast of
what's going on i'm the business
secretary i'm here i'm in your studio
i'm in a suit uh i'm not i'm not on
holiday
and we're absolutely focused on trying
to deal with this problem
where's the prime minister as well i
mean some people might be saying we've
had this terrible outlook for our
economy there are a lot of people who
are suffering right now not to mention
in the future
we thought we might see our leaders at a
time like this well i'm the business
secretary i'm here um i'm in regular
contact with prime minister and
chancellor they're completely on top of
what's happening let's take a look then
how individuals are coping with this we
heard yesterday that the energy price
caps going to be reviewed every three
months and every six months
do you welcome that or do you worry at
all about individuals who will now see
prices rise in october and january at a
time when they they want to be able to
keep the heating on i think it's a real
problem um and i'm sure that a future
chancellor
and the future prime minister whoever he
or she is uh will will address this very
very quickly um the reason for having
three month reviews is that with six
month reviews you had very steep uh
increases and that was uh very very
damaging as well but clearly there's a
there's an energy problem i mean all
over europe they're rationing gas
they've got to reduce their gas
consumption by 15 we're not doing that
in the uk but it's an issue that has to
be addressed and rishi himself uh i
thought very rightly said we're going to
have to intervene so even uh he who's
saying that we've got to keep taxes high
suggests and understands that there has
to be some more help to support people
okay well let's talk about what list
trust will do to support people rather
than rishi sunag last night she was
given a a specific question about a
woman's um situation a woman called
selena earning just over 10 000 pounds a
year
she's not going to benefit from the
the scrapping the rise in the national
insurance that liz trust is promising
and the green energy
levy which she's going to cut will only
take 150 pounds off her monthly bills so
she couldn't didn't seem to be able to
answer this question i mean is enough i
think she answered it very well
so remember
what she said
was that the big risk to this economy is
a recession a really damaging recession
and what happens in the recession is
that businesses go bust
unemployment goes up and growth
uh craters so that means there's a huge
risk to jobs huge risk to people being
able to earn a living
and that situation is going to be
disastrous for all of us and that's why
what liz is saying is that we can't
simply continue uh on the path that
we're on we can't simply pretend that
more of the same is going to work
because it frankly isn't okay so that's
looking to the future and we can argue
about the rights and wrongs of that but
for people like selena right now there's
a real need what's the immediate help
that people like her are going to get
from a liz cross government so i'm not
going to prejudge what a future chance
is going to say in a month or what the
whoever the prime minister is and you're
laying out all the people i can't i i
can't say because as you say it's an
immediate ask liz has said there's got
to be an emergency budget i think she's
the only one of the candidates who said
uh there'll be an emergency budget and
in that emergency budget i'm sure
there'll be immediate relief and
actually the way that liz is talking
about the economy is we need immediate
support now that's why she's talking
about tax cuts that's why she's talking
about
allowing people to keep more of their of
their hard-earned uh money uh the rishi
plan was for a tax cut at the end of the
next parliament which is 2029. that
isn't going to cut it that isn't going
to help people like selena who have
faced immediate
immediate uh urgent problems well you'd
agree wouldn't you that inflation is the
big problem here i mean the bank of
england's saying it's going to reach as
high as 13 by the end of the year and
you will also know that there are a lot
of economists who are very concerned
about tax cut cutting plans in this kind
of scenario they worry they're going to
be even more inflationary and we'll end
up with so no economist i've ever heard
of says the way to deal with the
recession is to put up interest rates
and to squeeze uh what they call fiscal
policy to put up taxes so if you're
facing a recession to face a world where
your interest rates are going up and
then you're putting taxes up on top of
that it is not helping uh growth i mean
that's obvious people no economist is
arguing for that well can you explain to
me why the government says that that
matching pay to inflation
is itself inflationary because it puts
more money in people's pockets why
cutting taxes doesn't have the same
effect because it puts more money in
people's pockets so i have never um
believed that the way to deal with the
recession when you're putting up
interest rates interest rates went up
yesterday by the largest amount since
1995 that's 27 years ago so on top of
that to put up taxes on people i think
is perverse it's not a way to deal uh
with a recession how do you think liz
trust got on last night i think she did
well the program that the audience
seemed to to favor richard i think she
was was very fluent he was very slick he
performed at the end um and uh i think
he did make an impact but i think what
he said which was essentially more of
the same we've got we taxes are at a
70-year high but i'm going to put them
up and he didn't say it that but that
was the implication of what he said i
think it's completely the wrong approach
and that's why i think it's very
important that liz uh wins so that we
can actually have a different approach
more of the same
uh it's not it's not gonna work
any lessons learned for liz truss's team
um after last night anything that you do
differently next time if she was in a a
one-to-one uh interview or debate well
i've always felt uh that it's always
good to come uh second because that's
the you the impression that you leave uh
but that's that was due to a coin toss
you mean you mean timing-wise
timing-wise yeah she won the coin i know
i know and she went first um but uh but
i that that was the only thing i thought
i thought she gave a very good account
of herself and she made a clear point
which i think a lot of viewers certainly
at home uh recognize is that we cannot
simply carry on as before we can't deal
with a recession by putting up people's
taxes to a 70 year high that doesn't
make any sense at all okay quasi
quattang we appreciate your time this
morning thanks very much indeed for
coming in thank you